[Music]
right off the bat explain to the world
where we are
i call it the atrium you know i'm a
dreamer
this is the award for when it was at 40
million 40
my recording studio here at home in
calabasas
you've made a ton of great music in here
haven't you tons of stuff here
dude i pinch myself probably on a daily
basis
at 58 years old motley crue's legendary
drummer tommy lee may have evolved from
his wild ways
but he's still rocking out
[Music]
tomorrow tommy drops his first solo
album in 15 years
andro explain this album i
separated all the female energy tracks
and i separated all the male energy
tracks
that's where the title came from andro
which is you know abbreviation for
androgyny i covered a print song
it's called when you were mine which is
mind-blowing
[Music]
and you look at back in the day you guys
really were
very android with the way you dressed i
mean
it was crazy we were there with you in
1985
oh this is your first
ever et interview oh my god you can bop
to it you can
you can you know shake your fist to it
it's just a
good throbbing rock and roll what a trip
road trip wow what would you tell them
put a helmet on that was right when it
was about them
[Applause]
and to commemorate the release of andro
tommy's wife of nearly two years 34 year
old brittany
gave him an unbelievable gift okay
open them
she takes my rolls-royce and wraps it
in the album colors my roles is
half pink and blue and it's got my name
on it the album artwork and stuff but
just
drive this around yeah do all your own
you don't have to hire a publicist
in many ways though she has been like
kind of the perfect
partner for you hasn't she totally i
think everybody's
a little crazy she's got super good
crazy
i spend a lot of time with my cheeks
hurt because we laugh a lot tommy's
inner circle of friends
is fittingly a motley crew that includes
john travolta
tommy has been there for him after the
devastating loss of his wife kelly
preston in july
how's he doing he's doing really well
i just talked to him yesterday um his
kids are doing wonderful
because i mean i'm sure it doesn't ease
the pain
at all but what a lovely man he's
probably the sweetest
man i think i've ever met
you